これじゃあ肇社長です
[音楽]
日駆除はきたなぁリックに開きました
道路もグランドも砂派はもカラッパも陸はねぇあっ
というわけでも陸上にいるのがちょっと嫌になってきたんで私はず3冊を胸の免許を
取りに行きたいと思います
時代は海うみいいなと思いましてちょっと船の免許とって自由に船運転歴は
めちゃくちゃないか最もすることできるんじゃねっていうことを考えつきまして
ちょっと船の免許を取りに行きたいと思いますね私が撮りたい免許そんなめちゃくちゃ
世界なんか大戦艦ヤマトみたいなあんなデカイ船を運転してるわけじゃなくてなんか
ほどよい大きさのクル座
なんか小さくもないし暴徒とかでもない
もっとこうしっかりしたような船は運転できるようになりたいなということで5型船舶
免許というものを取りに行きたいと思います船の免許の取得には大体の4日間ぐらい
かかるみたいなんですけどもなんとか先生に無理を言って二日間
またの実技行ったりなんか勉強したりいろいろすると思うんですけどもみっちり2日間
でミンジョとれるコースでメニューをとっていきたいとおもいます
広げて実際に免許取りにいった様子1日目と2日目ご覧ください
どうぞさぁ始まりましたはじめ社長の船舶免許取得 day 1今回清水浩の近くの
免許教室にさせていただいております
こちらがせいぜいですね
と踊っていただくまでどういうことをやっていただくかっていうのを簡単に
オリエンテーションとして
入ってるけど勉強取得までどういう流れになるか説明させていただいております
もう4日かかるところ2日なんで結構つめつめのスケジュールです
はい覚えることがいっぱいでせすんげー分厚い教習本をいただきました
けれどもそれが好き
はいよろしくお願いしますというわけで1日目はですねなんか学科教本この本で
ひたすら勉強します船の知識とかもそうなんですけども海もね道路と一緒です陸上の
道路と一緒で決まったルールがあるんですけども僕は本当の指の知識ゼロなんで全く
無知の状態からしっかりと勉強させていただきました
はいご覧くださいこの髪のケアの汗びっしょりですもう
へんっ
クーラーが壊れてるめっちゃ暑かったんでも休憩中はしっかりと根づいていただきまし
た
それで先生もしっかりとタブレット誰かを使ってわかりやすく現行の見方の説明とかし
てくれてますね船は猫こうキャスト低気圧を見極めたり本当にスレ主がこうしていいの
かし行動しちゃダメなのかを見極めるのも船長の役目ですというわけでしっかりとお昼
カラー夕方までもバッジ
し勉強をしっかりしていきたいとおもいます
[音楽]
ん
ございました
というわけで初日が終わりました集計含めて9時間ぐらいかな
葛間のまずは学科させらもう学ぶという感じでや
めっちゃッ
全然年カフェデートがの好きなさせ技でまずで意味がわからなかったです今日なんか
知らない分なんかすごい
決起しっかり聞けたんであの比較的堪能し買ったですはいこれ2日間にわたるねつぎは
結構実技かな
実際に乗ることが多いと思うけどそ日はもう9時間という恐ろしい時間の座学ひたっ
すら朝から夕方まで詰まっておりました二日目も頑張っていきたいとおもいます
いやー
ます
はい続いてでーっつです
おはようございまーす
うためでございます2日目はザクが終わったんですけども2日目は絶対に文に乗ったり
することがあるんで
ちょっと緊張してますあの口叫ぶ海の底とが苦手なんで
あの落ちるとちょっと怖いですございますいらっしゃいますね
にしましたん
いよいよすすめに塗りましさあ良いよスネの記者がないきました
で僕実は海濃いんですよねちょっと宇美町二章みたいなところだって産んでも好きに
なるかもしれない今日
看板は日々復興
艦これっ発射と思います
現像この振れだって放送法
8こちらの方が運転席になって安全とレバーがありはまあサンドラ車と同じように明
生きると3
左横に切ると左の方につながっていきますそれからですね
a こちら義母パネバーってマーキュリーマーズパッチとスロットルが一体となって
ます上の方には知らんけど前進
さあの方にダウト更新西部署ながら複数あるけど
はいどれぐらいの勢いでレバー操作ってな
行っていくと何してしっかり理解しておりますよなんか聞く限りですねうんてい方も車
より簡単なイメージでした
こので行ってみますかはいじゃあ運転席のもロボッ
[音楽]
ブーブーをしっかりと学んでいきますブーバーし
休憩
が運転できるらしいですよ
[音楽]
ん
はいそして良いよ地図木訓練ですマリオすみませんであります
ございますだお願いしまーす9位
動き出しましたん
今度は斜めになってきますんで見ていてください
前オス民謡左ます蒙古族の連合軍がお願いします
えっ
me
[音楽]
入って上でこれで代々ロング10キロぐらいなスピードでてるっぽいですね結構速いし
ながら波で跳ねるんですよね
フックですけど
にはそうやってみます久代運転列できるのでしょうか
しっかりと確認してますねこれまあ
に塗って
でもどこの3足でこちら白い灯台どこに売っていませんでし
方向的には合ってますはい
んですねえええ
[音楽]
ん
グループ e
goo
さっきほしいのが出てきました遠くから見るとこんな感じですね結構早いほうだと思い
ます
wh
ええええええ
[音楽]
wh
いてちゃいまーす
nude girl までを持って行っちゃいます
ニュートラルとパイその後ずっと方向転換人面救助とかの練習をさせていただきました
そしてこれはですねするだろうねあの蛇行運転ですね車体よめちゃくちゃ方へ向けて
運転する練習です
あの僕バイクの免許持ってるね結構ねか食べてるのに恐怖感なくてガッツリ傾けて運営
することができました
そして楽しんでいる私の特徴口が開くんですとペンを楽しんでいるみたいです
me
aname
そして実技が終わって港に到着しました事態ですね降りるときのこの紐の結び方とかも
全部勉強しましたとても大事です
そして最後は学科のテストです2日が学んだことがたくさん問題に出てきますまあ
できるができない彼はこの顔を見れば分かると思います
なりましたね
ああああああん
[音楽]
はい時で始まりました50分間のマークテストですよね久々にねぇ
勉強ぽいことをちゃんとしたんで結構緊張したけど楽しかったです
[音楽]
はいと受けてすぐ結果じゃないんですけどもこれで一応
船舶免許の全課程が終了しましたお疲れ様でした俺
買えというわけで2日間終わりましたを使いました
あの先生もすごい良かったんですけども言えつ一つだけ言わせていただくと
あついあづらく壊れててもう本当に戦争になるんじゃないかってくらい過ぎ暑かった
けどめっちゃくちゃ勉強しましたね海のルールとかすっげあるんですねほんとにあれし
茶ねこ列車だメット通りとレーザー頭には入った
んでもし僕が免許取得したら海でちゃいけないことをしっかり守って法律的に問題なく
いろんななんか恐れ通り取れたらいいなと思っておりますというわけで
結果羽生ようです
一丁で z あの店だと思うんですけどもそんなに定数が車の陰でみたいに何か
キューバに取るとかそういうわけじゃないんですけどそれでもやっぱ問題がね船の話だ
からねほんと追うと知識が無さ過ぎてに公園ですけどもう早速合否判定を制定に聞こう
と思います
調子悪い大山するを言えればそうですあお世話になりますした
始めそうです
お世話になりますお電話使えそうでしたそれから視聴ありがとうございます
つまりズバリ聞くんですけどはいコーヒ判定はどうでしたか
いい
負荷が重い昼間であるようしていたがいいだけ火災が果実に共にはい
合格でそうありがとうございます
熱狂の方が少し時間かかりますがそれで度キアが采配
でございますのではいわかりましたありがとうございますまた機会がありましたら
よろしくお願いします
はい
ありがとうございましたございました3としますそういうわけで無事光学しました
t
ということで最後にドッキリしていきたいと思いますレッツゴー
[音楽]
というわけで運転できるスキル雨に付いた知識があるということでい先生が一緒に乗っ
てたら運転していっぽいんでアート港の方がで船で運転してきて畑のメンバー今港の方
に来てるんですけど船運転した奴が初めに育ったらドッキリやっていきたいと
思います
ん
[音楽]
見ています
このよっん
me
いい天気ですね
ていいですねー
[音楽]
歴史場所ですあっつえーわ
me
第10弾ん
[音楽]
違うやろうかっ
じゃあすぐの音が鳴りません
car 俺 raion
焦る事をん
rar
me
ちょっとん
あっは
[音楽]
blr